День добрий шановні глядачі Deutsche
Welle українською Мене звати Максим
драбок Я Спеціальний кореспондент
deutschevelle тут на мюнхенській
конференції з безпеки нагадаю що це
Найбільший у Європі форум з міжнародною
політики та безпеки куди приїжджають
лідери країн прем'єр-міністри експерти
та багато-багато різних оглядачів весь
політичний бомонд фактично Європи і не
тільки А цього західного світу і порозі
мною експерт німецький експерт
Мюнхенської конференції з безпеки
ніколанги він німець Але який вивчив
українську і чудову на його говорить
Добрий вечір пане Ніко пане Максим
Добрий вечір трішечки сюди щоб ви бачили
Я трішечки поверніться будь ласка щоб
можна було
говорю українською можливо з помилками
але виставте такий час ви знаєте що
треба більше говорити українською мовою
нічого нічого це якраз практика дуже
добре буде для
вас Отже
перше запитання такого власне типу
президент Зеленський у виступі сьогодні
сказав що протягом року можна досягнути
Перемоги на вашу думку це реально чи ні
перемога це означає що
росіяни вже не будуть на території
України і я думаю зараз ми бачили що
Україна вже
50%. цей території де булій росіяни вона
вже
освободила тому я думаю це можливо це
можливо якщо буде підтримка із
підтримка партнерів для України і я
думаю добре Я думаю що дуже добре що на
реакції сьогодні і
сказали що вони АТО ви на довгострокові
підтримку Україною Я думаю що це що це
гроші зі мною
якраз ми заговорили про макрона
буквально перед початком конференції як
коротко поспілкувався із Президентом
Франції макроном який запевнив що його
країна і захід будуть пліч-о-пліч з
Україною до перемоги власне що вважати
перемогою це компроміс досягнення це
повне звільнення українських територій
включно із Криму що саме вважається
перемогою
для мене це абсолютно Ясно
повне звільнення території України і
кордони України як ми визнали офіційно
це код до одної 91-го року і це включає
Крим це для мене абсолютно Ясно Так
скажіть будь ласка як сприйняли виступ
президента Зеленського тут у Мюнхені він
робив це віртуально нагадаю минулого
року він приїздив сюди особисто зараз
через зрозумілі причини Ні що змінилося
за цей час і як сприйняли його виступ
Ну ми бачили перед виступом президента
Зеленського також фільм
і це змінює які були і у нас і у
президента Зеленського і перш за всех
України і я думаю все тут зрозуміють що
меншинська конференція безпеки і
дискусії про безпеки це не якісь якась
інтелектуальна робота це реальні люди
це реальний реальний змінний поганий
зміни для людей для багато людей в
Україні і все зрозуміють що це дуже
важлива дуже серйозно до цього
підставити І як
там гостін керівник мюнченської
конференції сказав з самого початку Ми
багато що зробили але треба більше
зробити щоб підтримати Україну і
звичайно президент Зеленський особисто
Він дуже емоційно
говорив про ситуацію і це дуже важливо
що він мав такий можливість Але
освічена була би дуже добре якщо він був
особисто тут але Ми домовились що він
буде
наступного року він буде особисто коли
буде мир в Україні коли буде перемога
так тобто сподіваємося що наступного
року президент Зеленський буде тут
особисто це означатиме що Україна
досягла Перемоги нагадаю що мене звати
Максим Драбов я Спеціальний кореспондент
Deutsche Welle тут на мюнхенській
конференції з безпеки а поруч із зі мною
ніколанги німецький експерт з безпеки
який вивчив українську мову дуже чудово
побачити без помилок майже нею говорить
і Ми продовжуємо ставити запитання також
Якщо ви хочете поставити своє запитання
будь ласка пишіть нижче і Мої колеги
мені допоможуть і надішлють Отже Пане
лангеска скажіть будь ласка
найбільше зараз потребує Україна що
досягти цієї Перемоги про яку Ми щойно
говорили я думаю саме важливе питання
зараз це е-е боєприяси
боєприпаси
і не тільки боєприпаси але і дуже
важлива зараз збільшення виробництва
боєприпасів особливо в Європі американці
вони з цим розпочинали і зараз дуже
важливо що також збільшення виробництва
у нас перейшло Я думаю тут в мюнсі не
будуть зараз багато переговорів Тому що
тільки Тут також є і представники і
політики і
виробництво щоб щоб цього говорити і я
думаю
це це саме важливе питання і потім зараз
важливо до України там є новий бойовий
машини там є новий танки але треба не
тільки
освоїти
Ці машини а треба зробити тренінги щоб
разом
бойовими танки і артилерії можуть робити
що ми
по стандарту НАТО
злагодження військ ми назвемо це
злагодження військ
Я думаю це такий рецепт що був прорив на
фронти і потім дальше
звільнення на території України
наскільки це часу скільки часу займає це
місяць два три Ну я думаю це буде деякі
тижні щоб освоїти технікою а потім ще
маневри щоб разом со всеми
працювати Ну деякий тиждень і місяць цей
там важлива що
фронт тримає в цей час де резерви
зроблять три неділі щоб потім вони
можуть в атаку ходити і зробити провід
Тобто ми можемо говорити про український
Контрнаступ наприкінці весни це
найшвидше правильно розумію ну я не можу
точно сказати коли це буде І можливо
також нерозумно говорити про те коли це
буде але я думаю що це можливо для
України зробити такий Контрнаступ якщо
буде дальше і підтримка із боєприпасами
і з новими танками і бойовими машинами
це ну значить Зараз дуже складна фаза
тому що і тут русский атаки на повним
фронті і треба ще трошки часу щоб
зробити цей тренінг а потім я думаю
ситуація буде покрашувати таку зараз
знову ж таки говорять після танків
одразу всі переключилися на літаки на
винищувачі наскільки є реальним їх
отримання України цього року
Ну я я не думаю що із моєю точку зору
все це саме важливе питання і я порадую
більше говорити про конкретні
підтягнення збільшення виробництва
боєприпасів інші підтягнення і зараз ці
кроки зробити
літаки можуть можуть бути важливими
після цього коли був прорив на фронт
Якщо звільнити територію і для підтримки
української армії на землі но це е-е
треба зараз Ну не такі
громкий дискусії зробити треба зробити 3
Никита пілотів і спокойно працювати І
щоб потім можливо цей крок і зробити
Отже найголовніше каже паланка це
боєприпаси тому що зараз саме це
потрібно на фронті потім Звісно що танки
і літаки вже так розумію для
завершального етапу звільнення Криму чи
чи ну звільнення української території я
не скажу де але я думаю це права України
це зробити і літаки могут допомагати і в
Німеччині це
особлива така дискусія яка відрізняється
від танків Я думаю тому що танки там
німецький леопарди вони дуже важливі і
виробництва
і це експорт і треба зробити також
політичне вирішення щоб експорт можливі
але літаки Я не думаю що ми говоримо про
німецький літаки Я думаю там там один із
варіантів може бути f16 і Ну там є інші
країни які можуть це зробити І я рада що
наприклад Нідерланди і Італія і Велика
Британія вже порція Аварії що вони
готовий на тренінги пілотів і це я думаю
гарний крок зараз а тепер Давайте
поговоримо власне про Німеччину і про її
можливе і бажане лідерство отче е-е як
наші глядачі стежили Німеччина довгі
місяці Влада дискусії чи до постачання
Танків і дозволу на реекспортанків
німецького виробництва леопард
при цьому у багатьох українців ставлення
до німців через ці вагання зокрема
Прем'єр канцлера ФРН Шульца дещо так
були Скажімо так не дуже позитивні тим
не менше хочу нагадати що саме Німеччина
є Найбільшим постачальником зброї та
іншого озброєння на континентальний
Європі тобто номер один на
континентальній Європі якщо ми не
рахуємо Сполучені Штати і Великобританію
Отже зараз на вашу думку вже щось змінив
свою позицію він буде більш рішучим без
змагань постачати Україні збройні
боєприпаси які ви говорили зрештою танки
Ну я думаю що
ми бачили в минулому році що
Німеччина і керівництво канцлера шоста
зробить правильний крок але зробить це
правильний крок і не дуже швидко Я думаю
це важливо що на тільки конференціях як
наприклад сьогодні тут і разом з
президентом і президентом макроном
будуть дискусії як швидше це зробити
Німеччина разом з іншими партнерами але
я думаю тиск
завжди допомагав і тиск від партнери
втіск від України і також від німецького
суспільства і грає дуже важливий і я
тільки можу сказати з точки зору
Мінської конференції безпеки ми будемо
далі і тикати щоб швидше німе зробить
таке рішення
так до речі теж спостерігається певна
Скажімо так лібералізація і посилення
позиції керівництва Мюнхенської
конференції зараз новий очільник - це
його дебют тут порівняно із попередником
з паном Ішим героєм як змінилися
риторика А так і ставлення до Росії до
е-е вирішення цієї проблеми я нагадаю що
е-е нинішнього очільник Мюнхенської
конференції доволі різко висловився що
потрібна де пунітизація Росії для того
щоб вона повернулася до клубу
цивілізованих країн Отже Скажіть будь
ласка наскільки ця позиція зі слів вже
перейде до практики до конкретних дій Я
думаю це дуже важливий сигнал що
мінческая конференція безпека безпеки
сказав сказала що
Росія і Іран
вони тут не будуть в цьому році
і ми дуже надалі в минулому році коли ми
були тижні до війни що було би зліва
поговорити з росіянами але в минулому
році вони різко отказали від
того що тут говорити і ми зараз знаємо
чому І я думаю це зараз зараз дуже
важлива сказати що Росія
не стоїть в цьому кругу партнерів які
тут разом працюють і
це також так стосовно Ірану і я я лічно
я я радий що у нас зараз така чітка
чітка позиція так говорить що про Росію
ці заяви про можливе застосування
тактичної ядерної зброї і так далі це
більше шантаж Росії чи це реальна
загроза
якщо вони далі не матимуть успіху на
полі бою то відповідно Чиє це загрозою
Чи все ж таки це вони лякаються шантаж
ми зробили опитування передмической
конференції безпеки і в Україні і там
Українці
більшість українців Вони сказали Даже
якщо буде тактично я до нас зброя вони і
дали будуть
свободу і рухати тому я не думаю що
такі
психірологічні ігри
вони вже мають дуже великий ефект міф
України імені у нас чи готовий захід до
можливого розпаду Росії власне так вони
завжди побоювалися західні крилами на
увазі щоб ядерна зброя не потрапила в
якісь руки терористів і так далі у
випадку розпаду можливого Росії і так
далі чи зараз психологічно є такий
просте що обробляються варіанти того що
Росія може
складатися з декількох частин Ви знаєте
це для мене не дуже важливо питання
зараз
в Німеччині дуже багато говориться
завжди А що думає Путін А як відчуває
себе Путіна що буде з Росією для мене
особисто це не дуже важливо дуже важлива
зараз як підтримувати Україну я йшов
забитий що дальше підтримати
міжнародний система правил яка і в
інтересах Німеччини і я свої ресурси не
буду не буду складати в думки про пути
отже і ми не будемо думати про нього нам
своє робити іти до перемоги нагадаю що
Зі мною був Ніко Ланге це німецький
експерт який Як бачите і чуєте чудово
говорить українською мовою Ми підбили
своєрідні підсумки першого дня
Мюнхенської конференції з безпеки
залишайтеся з нами дивіться далі
Deutsche Welle на всі платформах YouTube
Facebook наш інтернет-магазин тому
будемо на зв'язку А ми побігли далі
стежити і брати інтерв'ю в інших
політичних діячів так що Разом до
перемоги і Гарного вечора
мені треба